[Musique]
c'est une ambiance festive qui anime les
rues de Saint-Germain-en-Laye quelques
jours après la journée de l'Europe je
suis sur la place du Marché Neuf puis se
tient toute la journée la 17e édition du
marché européen un événement organisé
par la ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
avec l'aide de la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines
[Musique]
le marché européen c'est de pouvoir
montrer un petit peu à nos concitoyens
au saint-germain-nois et à toute la
région un petit peu ce qu'est l'Europe
ce que propose l'Europe aussi bien sur
le plan que culinaire puisque nous avons
beaucoup de stands culinaires mais
également sur le plan comment dirais-je
culturel nous avons cinq jumelages donc
quatre en Europe donc vraiment le marché
européen c'est de montrer et de prouver
à nos si toi à nos concitoyens que
l'Europe est au cœur de notre vie
[Musique]
parmi tous les stands du marché on
retrouve évidemment des stands
d'information notamment celui de la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines dont la
mission est de rapprocher les citoyens
de l'Union européenne pourquoi ce marché
européen est-il important en quoi c'est
important de mettre en valeur cette
culture européenne
parce que je crois que à travers notre
connaissance mutuelle en tant que
européen à travers notre histoire
commune en tant que européen nous
pouvons tous chacun
œuvrer à nos échelles différentes pour
la paix la Concorde européenne et nous
permettre en réalité de d'avoir un
continent plus fort dans ce contexte
global qui est de plus en plus anxiogène
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens bon il
est maintenant 12h30 l'heure d'aller
manger un morceau ça tombe bien
aujourd'hui des dizaines de commerçants
proposent des spécialités culinaires de
toute l'Europe spécialités roumaines
suédoise espagnol ou encore belge les
visiteurs n'ont que l'embarras du choix
c'est quoi les spécialités culinaires de
la Belgique aujourd'hui on a ramené on a
fait des moules frites et on a aussi
ramené de la carbonade flamande ce qui
est c'est quand même
un peu brune et c'est la recette de mon
arrière arrière grand-mère
[Musique]
des sourires du soleil et de la musique
pour les organisateurs la 17e édition du
marché européen est une grande réussite
moi je vous laisse je vais aller goûter
cette fameuse carbonade flamande